Oh feathers and stuff oh my god I feel a
lot better about that is cool the way I
feel about subscription boxes is that a
lot of things that are offered are
things that you might not really need
every single month do you really know
what you'd want well that or did someone
tell you I think you just described
consumerism subscription boxes are fun
but they're dangerous because you always
think you're gonna come subscribe and
you never unsubscribe kind of like
getting given a gift by someone that
doesn't know you could be dreadful why
not just pick what you want it's like a
blind date right and I know that there's
like style ones and fashion ones really
trust someone else and I don't know that
I could do that I've got I'm excited to
try out these weird boxes just to see
what people can come up with and try to
like pass it on to other people people
are so weird
alright it's time to take a look at
these boxes
[Music]
let's see okay there's a paper oh my god
this is a dead this is a box of like
strange days of the month national
submarine day right with your beetle
submarine socks you can wear them really
actually those are finally cute socks
yes if you can I have this I love this
mug is it for Earth Day
I know I love mine oh sorry Charlie Day
these are all the characters oh there's
more
okay this is amazing my practical mind
says where would you put these you put
them on the shelf
this is cute fun thing to give someone
oh this is for stress Awareness Day it's
called a bike trinket tray so it's a
it's a tray for your trinkets oh I would
use it as an ashtray because I don't
smoke but if you're stressed never mind
let me not promote the reactions of like
discovering was and there was like worth
it for me but also these are like really
cute presents I think
because I've done subscription boxes I
will say unless there's another box
inside of this box this is a little
boring oh I know slime as a thing
because I've seen the internet we have
four types of slimes melted jellybeans I
mean I love this in a way once the
melted jellybeans oh this is jellybeans
that makes sense does it smell like
jelly can smell it it's always it does
Bob yeah it's just like a very much a
sugar rush do not eat the slime what
about the other stuff I wouldn't eat
this if I was a kid oh wow this smells
great how do you put it back oh wait
make activator one teaspoon of borax
powder so this is like a kit to make
things it's to make it not sticky
oh so this is something that I have to
put in work for and I don't want my
boxes to make me work no I would never
spend that much money on a slime box
when you can literally find instructions
on the internet and make it for cheaper
100% you can buy all these things for
waging this is a box that you sent to
someone that you don't like if you were
a slime liver because it's got all kinds
of things I think it smells fun it's
really cute I think it is fun for kids I
think it'll be a fun kids box
I personally don't need slime yeah no
more bottles of slime every month I
think this is really cute for like a
family who might have a bit of
disposable income for their children a
spots last
[Music]
it's a box that says study learn collect
when I was a child I used to dig up and
collect bones bones specimen every month
this is like your spooky taxidermy box
almost it's so light Oh feathers and
stuff oh my god I feel a lot better
about that is cool we got the skull of
the eastern mold is insectivore that
promises to add another dimension to
your skull collections
so grab your magnifying glass and let's
start exploring this unique skull
I just hope they didn't kill them all
for this no I measures like a cadaver
like you probably need signed up to be
an organ donor
oh this is so much okay so it's an axial
skull so they don't lie to us okay this
is it's weirder it's the probably the
weirdest thing but not weird in like a
scary way I like spooky things but this
is too far for me personally one of the
first things you will notice are the
teeth the sharp distinct pattern of the
teeth allowed the mold to easily slice
through earthworms oh cool I feel really
like just like I'm violating the small I
feel like if you taught like fourth
grade science having this stuff come in
every month would be really great I
think if you had a really interesting
child that might have to be a murderer
that child would love this books again
like I don't know what I would do with
this on the Reg I love weird rodents
right that's the thing I love I don't
love having their skulls on display but
I love that because they're just so like
misunderstood and adorable
I had a great time with the bookses but
they're very specific to very specific
types of people which is kind of cool
there's something out there for
everybody my favorite box was the box
that was about the days I just didn't
fit the other two targets exactly but
they make sense they make sense for the
demographic with their mentoring if I
had a lot of money I would get a
sufficient books full of someone as a
gift cuz then I'd have to keep it all in
my house every month you're a lazy
Christmas shopper you have a lot of
people to shop for you think you saw one
of these you have a lot of white
elephant games to play 100 great for
that yeah
[Music]
[Music]